southern california the site for big
league baseball tonight petco park where
the astros and the san diego padres
continue
this three-game series tonight it's the
middle game of the three-game set davies
making start number six of the year for
the san diego padres one out of no one
on for second baseman jose altuve
as he sends this one into right field
it's slicing and it's hit deep and will
myers will play it off a wall
jose altuve into second base standing
with a double altuve continues to hit
well
that is now seven hits in his last four
games that was a sinker they didn't sink
at all it stayed up and altuve took
advantage of it so the astros have two
men on with one out for kyle tucker
doesn't chase down low davies continues
to miss low and the astros stay patient
and now the bases are loaded with one
out for julie guriel and maybe the best
guy you want up with the bases loaded on
the astros is coming up and that's julie
guriel and yuli sends one in the air to
right center field well hit myers going
back he's near the track he puts it away
altuve can jog home tagging and heading
to third base will be correa astros
score a run on the sac fly by yuli
guriel welcome back after the day off
number 64. brandon belak is going to be
on the mound for your astros in san
diego last three starts have been very
good for brandon b lock trent grisham
left-handed hitting center fielder to
start things off
this one is driven to right field hit
deeply back goes reddick at the wall
that ball is gone
good start for the padres trent grisham
with one swing of the bat ties the game
all tied at one grisham hits his fifth
home run of the year for the padres
1-1 ball game from petco park one out
and manny machado standing in
this is driven to center field george
springer going back he looks up and that
ball's gone
manny machado with a home run to
straightaway center padres with their
second solo home run of this first
inning and that one puts them on top two
to one minnie machado
i'll bring up taylor jones
he's playing great baseball at strike
three first strikeout of the night for
zach davies two down two down here in
the second inning dustin garneau
swinging a miss and davies comes back to
strike him out back-to-back case for
davies it's 2-1 padres will myers
against belak
in the year to deep left field for myers
tucker's going back and home runs are
flying out of petco park tonight will
myers with his seventh home run of the
year and the padres take a 3-1 lead
myers will touch them ball
one goal on top of the order trent
grisham
and now he drives it out towards deep
right center field does that have enough
back goes reddick at the wall it's gone
trent grisham with a three-run home run
his second home run of the night and the
padres take a 6-1 lead
home run number four of the night for
your san diego padres comes ty france
ninth member of this padres team to bat
in the second inning
to center field and that's going to get
in for a big hit in front of springer
from third comes tatis and the padres
take a 7-1 lead yeah we've seen this act
before dawn base is loaded jake cronin
were standing in
this to right field reddick going back
at the wall this
is grand slam diego
another grand slam
jake croninworth takes it out of the
yard to right the grand slams just keep
coming on it's 11-1 padres and this
george springer leads off
strike three call springer knew it takes
with him the third strikeout for zach
davies
taylor jones
taylor jones sends one deep to left
field and taylor jones has connected on
his first major league home run
congratulations to the 26 year old from
gonzaga taylor jones welcome to the club
taylor jones that ball was destroyed
dustin garneau
he offered and that is strike three
strikeout number four
for davey second time garno is down by
way of the k two down on the fifth
louise terrence sacrifice bunt and a
ground out now he sends one to the gap
in left center field there's his first
hit of the year that'll get through to
the track and the wall and terrence to
second base with a one-out double now
two va at first base and brings up
carlos correa
chops one down the third baseline fair
ball long throw for ty france and he'll
get it there nice play but really nice
play by ty flat-footed kind of and a
nice stretch down towards home plate by
eric hosmer taylor jones one for two a
homer
that is strike three and that is the top
of the seventh sympathetic stretch 11-2
padres
and brings up trent grisham
fly ball left field back goes stubs at
the wall
three home runs tonight for trent
grisham
six for the padres padres take a 12-2
lead
this is a two-run shot for trent grisham
abraham toro coming up here for the
astros
on the ground right side naylor will
flip to perdomo makes a nice play to end
the ball game
well the padres come up with a victory
tonight in a big way